hey everybody its Jessie and today I
haven't even done anything yet and I
already have one thumbs down on this
video so I'm not mad about it
I just wonder what what did I do I don't
have a thumbs down it was already there
like ten minutes ago so if you do
dislike one of my videos let me know why
I don't even care if you mean about it
only cry a little bit but let me know
why and if you don't want to call me out
like in front of other people because
you're afraid you know you people get
mad about it or whatever just direct
message me I won't call you out a few
direct message me and are critical or
whatever because I want to make this
stream better so I really really
appreciate all the positive feedback
that I get and lately I've been getting
a lot of positive feedback I've had some
direct messages on Twitter and emails
and you all been you know just really
awesome and encouraging and I really
appreciate that
but if you don't like what I'm doing I
you know if you have you know two
minutes to explain why that would really
help me out alright so I want to do two
things today
one thing obviously is make these custom
post types like like the title of this
the stream says the other thing though
is I want to show you an error that I
inadvertently caused when I set up the
load balancer and that Sebastian caught
so hey so Sebastian he's often in the
live chat I don't even remember the last
time he missed a live chat but last
night Sebastian
direct message me on Twitter and sent me
a screenshot of some errors that he was
seeing and I had not seen these errors
before and once I did a little bit of
research I found out what the problem is
and so I think this is a problem that
would be easy to have if you're doing
load balancing I mean I've been working
with next for a while now probably at
least six months I've been working with
next maybe longer what month is it
yeah probably about six months and I've
read through a lot of their
documentation and I never saw this
before so what's happening is this let
me show you it's not gonna show up now I
might have to show you on the yeah it's
not going to show up here it'll show up
on the server so let me bring in my oops
actually I could have done it here yep
let me bring this in and I'll go to one
of these servers and let me let me
change the color real quick because I
know I had some I think it's there we go
if you're using item and you press
command I it will bring this up and you
can change your colors but I just I
haven't figured out how to get it to
persist and change everything at once I
haven't really taken that much time to
try to figure it out the colors there we
go maybe a week or two ago I had
somebody that said that this black
background was was just killing their
eyes so I want to lighten it up a bit
and so basically I'm going to go into
one of the servers if you haven't seen
the other videos where I set up load
balancing right now this this site which
I'll show you here in a second so this
site that we've been working on for a
while I'm doing this for anybody who's
new is a react site and it's running
next j/s which basically lets you
scaffold your react app and it provides
server-side rendering and routing right
off the bat so it does a lot of cool
stuff for you so you don't have to worry
about that and you can just get started
in you'll get to working on your app and
I guess I had it right here too I didn't
have to bring that one over so once I
split it on to two different droplets on
digitalocean so there's two instances of
this app running and then I set up a
load balancer I kind of use easy mode I
set up the digitalocean load balancer
it's like 20 bucks a month and it makes
it really easy to do load balancing so
at some point I would love to do like a
live stream of setting up a load
balancer maybe like from scratch and but
for now that was a good first step for
me into the world of load balancing but
what happened that I didn't expect was
this I should go so I'm going to open up
this file okay so when you build your
next app so when you run you know npm
run build or yarn build or whatever you
want to run it
I think it's next build so however you
run it it creates a unique ID well you
need to build ID so my my deployment
process for this is that I develop
locally I push all the changes to a
github repo and then I log on to the
server I pull down the changes from
github I build and then I start the app
so on the server on one server there's
one build ID and then you switch to the
other one this is the other one not
logged in right now with Logan the other
one I have another build ID so there are
two different IDs so then what would
happen is I would I would come in here
and I would click around and react would
detect that the build ID was not the
idea that it expected so this error
wouldn't happen all the time
it would only happen from what I could
tell from what I read I think it was
happening because sometimes part of the
site was loading from one server and
part from another server so like you
know not every page has to load every
resource right so you might get you know
one request would get sent to one server
one droplet and then a request you make
a little bit later when you go to a
different page might get sent to another
one that's what seemed like was
happening and then next detected like
hey there's there's a difference in
these I build ID numbers and it was
giving me lots of errors okay so I
wonder if I can show I'd like to show
you what the errors look like in case
you get them so you know let me let me
look here at the screenshot that
Sebastian sent
let me bring this over
it's kind of small try to zoom in okay
so I can make this bigger so these are
the areas that I was getting see invalid
build ID basically there were actually
two forms of this error there was it was
displaying sometimes like this and
sometimes it was displaying another way
but basically both both times it was
saying something about a build build err
built idea okay so now we've got rid of
those and here's how I fixed it so I was
a little bit proud of myself when I
thought about this so I didn't come up
with it completely on my own I found I
found this issue so somebody had had a
similar issue and they reported it here
in the github repo for next and then
after some possible solutions and
suggestions down here at some point
I may be right around here okay so
here's the suggestion to use a different
build ID so make manually add a build ID
that's the same ok the solution number
one was well just build once and then
copy that over and run that on two
different servers but that's not that
wasn't going to work with my deploy
process so I didn't want to change my
deployment process I want to find a
different solution so the solution was
just add something in add a step in to
your build process that changes that ID
to whatever you want it to be and make
sure it's the same so the suggestion
somewhere in the documentation for next
it also suggested you could use the ID
for the commit for the latest commit the
- - like the head to the master branch
and github I thought that's really cool
so that's exactly what I did
so check out my package.json here and
here's what I added just this part so in
the build process now I had this so this
command get Rev parse head just gives
you the ID and I know some of you
probably know all this and this is old
news for you but for there's a lot of
people who are just starting out who
might not be confident in their
command-line skills so I'm going to just
kind of explain what this does so I'm
going to copy this come in in here and
if you see this it just returns the ID
of the latest commit so that's what we
want we want this kind of unique ID but
we want it to be different for each
build but the same on both on both
servers okay
and then we're just automatically
putting this into this file so if you're
not familiar with this basically you
know you put the sign in here what is
this the greater than sign and then we
specify the file and so whatever this
returns becomes the contents of this
file so it worked
I now have those errors are gone the
build IDs are now the same so anyway I
thought that was a I mean it was a
tricky problem for me when I first saw
that last night I thought what is going
on I have no idea you know what this is
but not too bad after a little search so
anyway I definitely wanted to point that
out because I feel like if anybody had
been following what I did with load
balancing they probably got a similar
error if they were using next as well
and I didn't want to leave leave anyone
hanging without you know bringing that
up and explaining what I did so I mean
this is all on github now you could
check it out you know and add this to
your project if you need to if you're
having this
error I'm going to check the live chat
really quickly because I have some some
comments in here before we get into the
custom post types
oh man Martin says two hours way too
much it's a very good topic I liked the
video before WordPress API but really
two hours is way too much um yeah I kind
of agree with you I don't I don't know
let me know do you all like when I have
the long streams like two hours or do
you like it when I used to have a half
hour streams so when I first started
streaming I tried to set a half hour
limit so I would code for like 25
minutes and then I would answer
questions for five minutes and then I'd
be done because I thought the same way
like hey nobody is going to watch the
recording of a two hour video but a half
hours more doable so let me know what
you think it's just some of the more
like detailed things that I had to do
the more complicated things there is no
way I could get it done in 25 minutes so
I just kind of kept going so that we
could do the whole thing I didn't want
to break it up and have you know one
thing take like three or four days so
let me know I can definitely change it
up if if you all think it should be
shorter fine otherwise they'll kind of
keep it going now I am I am doing I
would kind of like to cut it back so
it's more like an hour not not the two
hours because that is a lot and I found
like honestly like after I I'm talking
for two hours uh my voice starts to go
so I think if I did that every day I
would lose my voice by the end of the
week so I mean it's not the end of the
world if my throat hurts a little bit
from this but I think would be better if
I still had a voice by the end of the
week all right a lot of people saying hi
hey everybody thanks for watching okay
you you get not sure how to pronounce
that I hope I pronounced it right you
can says please start the technology
from scratch that would help begin
increase up their level that everyone up
the level that would help everyone
thanks you rock awesome thank thank you
for the for the positive feedback there
I really would like to start from
scratch and I probably will end up
starting from scratch soon when I move
to my next project so this stream in
particular is just what I have to do at
work anyway I try to pick the most
interesting thing that I'm going to do
each day and save it for this livestream
time and I get a lot of them more boring
like copy and paste type of things out
of the way early on in the day so
sometimes we're doing more complex stuff
and sometimes we'll be doing beginner
stuff it's just it depends on what I
have to work on that day but I know I've
been saying this in promising this for a
while but I am going to do some tutorial
videos that will be pre-recorded and in
those videos I will go over basic stuff
and they'll be really targeted if
someone will be targeted just that
people who are really at the beginning
stages so that is coming I have some
outlines already ready for those videos
I just need some quiet time to do the
videos I've started to do one and then
all my kids came home and it was just
way too noisy and I don't have an office
at home I need I need like to make a
little office space where I could do
this so anyway let me
okay so Jordan says 30 to 60 minutes ok
that's reasonable that's kind of the
range that I think is probably best for
me
Rowan says I actually love these two 2.5
hours stream but some topics can
certainly be half or one hour ok cool
yeah I do I kind of agree with that it
it does depend on what we're doing as to
the length
see best to make sure topics are covered
completely but an hour max good okay so
an hour max an hour one and a half hours
break it up
okay so it seems like right around the
one hour range seems to be kind of like
the median of what people are saying so
I'm going to try to keep things like an
hour or less I will say a lot of the
time at the end does come like we kind
of get into a discussion about things so
the actual coding time sometimes isn't
that much but maybe maybe we can break
it up maybe there can actually be a
scheduled like question and answer time
so that we can split up and have videos
that are just coding and then videos
that are more Q&A I don't know I have to
think about that and see you know when
that would be good to do I do I do like
the idea Jordan says break it up into
different streams multiple streams per
day so like instead of making one long
stream that's two hours I could do for
half-hour streams so yeah that would be
a little bit more work just to set all
this times up and to make like video
thumbnails for that but I guess I could
use the same thumbnail and just change
part 1 part 2 part 3 so that's that's a
good idea I'll think about that one as
well sometimes I don't know ahead of
time how long a certain thing will take
Roland says spontaneous Q&A is better
yeah that's what I was thinking the
scheduled Q&A might not work out the you
know if we do get questions they just
kind of flow out of what we're doing
[Music]
Danny says we be doing WordPress
development stream yeah so I'm doing I'm
going to do that right now
sometimes I I'm not going to do a
dedicated stream for WordPress like
every you know every so often but every
day but occasionally I will need to do
WordPress stuff because I work with
WordPress websites sometimes so we'll be
incorporating that
so let me get to it it's already been
I'm talking here about you know cutting
down my stream time and I've already
spent the first almost 20 minutes on you
know kind of beside the topic I mean now
we haven't it was important we were
trying to break down and troubleshoot an
error so you know that was valuable but
I do want to get to it okay somebody's
joining an expecting wordpress I don't
want to be disappointed so here I have
let me move this over and just to show
you how we're going to do some of these
so I already have some custom post types
running and I'm going to bring over my
wordpress site as well to show you what
post types I have running and what it
kind of looks like here so I don't know
how familiar you all are with WordPress
it's a content management system that's
built on PHP and normally the way you
use WordPress is you have a theme and
that's you know rendered it's you know
PHP templates and it's all tied in here
with this admin panel and that's how
normal WordPress website works you know
normally like you know you click a link
it's a page refresh and everything
everything's rendered on the server
using PHP what I'm using WordPress is
I'm using the API so all the content
still goes in here and basically it's
still running PHP behind the scenes but
I don't use PHP to render anything okay
there the display portion of it what
people see with what the client sees you
know for instance this is built with
react and it lives on a different server
than this so when this page loads a
request is sent to WordPress saying I
want to certain data and then it comes
back in JSON format
and then I handle on this end sorting it
out and rendering it all so WordPress
now is in I think the term people use is
headless so we're using it as a headless
CMS so WordPress isn't usually a
headless CMS but we're using it in that
way here is that all we care about is
content going in here and we don't care
about display here we do all the display
stuff here so that's just a quick
overview in case you're wondering what
you know how WordPress ties in with with
react and what we're doing I will I'm
not going to go into a lot of the why of
doing it like this because I've covered
it before in videos and in the comments
to some of the videos early on but just
to to say a little I've found that when
I make sites like this they are much
faster than traditional WordPress sites
that I've done and I'm able to do
different things like yesterday we set
up it's not live yet but yesterday we
set up a like a live search that just
automatically gave us search results and
it was really cool
not that you that's not possible with a
normal WordPress site but this gives me
a lot of freedom to use the build tools
that I want and be able to do everything
in JavaScript you know using react
instead of having to do a lot of the
templating in PHP and now if someone was
really good with PHP maybe they'd like
to do in a different way but I'm not
great with PHP but I know enough to do
custom post types so let me show you
that what a custom post type is in case
you're not case you're not sure so this
is one custom post type it's called
nearby events so this isn't default in
WordPress I just made this name up
nearby events will go to add one okay
and I've also added some custom fields
and we'll probably add some of these
today I did not code these custom fields
in PHP
so what we'll do is I'll show you how to
code in PHP the custom post types but
then I'll show you the plug-in I use as
well to do all these fields for me since
I'm not really a PHP guy the custom post
types are pretty easy to do but all the
custom fields were just it was just too
much work for me it made more sense to
go with a plug-in and also if you're not
familiar with WordPress plugins will
cover it you know in a little while so
it'll make more sense but basically I
can just set out here's what I want
here's all the fields that I want this
gets put in here and then the data I get
the data basically like this this isn't
the same this is data for different
custom post type but it gives you the
same idea is that this is how I get the
data that gets put into here and then I
can do whatever I want with this in
react okay does that make sense
I'll check the live stream if this is
like completely confusing to you let me
know in the live chat and I can let me
know what's confusing and I can't
explain it otherwise I'm going to keep
keep going and show you how how we set
up these post types so there's probably
a little delay so I'm going to wait just
you know a few more seconds here to see
if anybody has a question at this point
because if you lost at this point I'd
rather like try to catch you up a little
bit then then you stay lost let's see
okay rowan says you you just request
content on api's probably as may be
overkill though but better than learning
a new CMS she was funny
I'm not sure if that was in response was
that in response to Danny or what also
yeah it probably is overkill but in this
particular case I didn't just need to
make a site I need to make a site that
was very impressive is there because of
the circumstances surrounding why I got
this project and everything I needed to
make it in a very impressive sight that
did more than a normal site would so
that's part of the reason why I went
with this as opposed to just a normal
WordPress site there are some other
really good reasons why and I think I
went over those a previous video so I'll
not go over them again here but if you
are thinking like like Rohan that maybe
this is overkill for just a normal
website I I don't completely disagree
with that but if you can make something
better and you have the time to do it
and the ability well you know why not do
it alright so I'm going to continue I
didn't have anybody say ok so that Rowan
said that wasn't response to Danny so
that's what I thought I just wanted to
Claire this clarification
okay Jake says overkill maybe it depends
on whether or not you're doing edits are
passing the site off the clients yeah
okay Jake I'm glad that you are I'm glad
you said that Jordan also mentions
building custom CMS is a lot of work
definitely a lot of work and Jake says
WordPress really easy to understand for
non techie people good I'm glad that
that you both brought up those points
because this this is exactly why I chose
WordPress as the CMS because it's so
easy for non tech people to use I'm not
going to be maintaining this site in
terms of content which is great I don't
I don't ever want to maintain content on
a site I just want to build new sites
and make them better so other people so
grad students who are getting their
degree here I work at the University who
are getting their you know their
master's degree here and are trying to
make a little bit extra money you know
while they're in school so I can pay
their rent and everything they're going
to be up updating the content so the
people updating this are constantly
going to change it's probably going to
be a new person every year every two
years they may or may not have any
experience okay so they're not getting
their degree in anything computer
related so they need something that's as
simple as possible so the idea is I make
pretty much everything that makes sense
edit able through WordPress and then I
make some tutorial videos so that the
new person would just be able to watch
you know a playlist of tutorials and
they would be able to go in here and
make any edits so I'm trying to make it
as easy as possible and make kind of
restrictions so I have restrictions on
some post types like if you upload an
image that's you know a certain size if
it's not at least let's say 600 pixels
wide then it won't display because I
don't want pixelated looking images on
the site so even if somebody were to
upload you know a really small image
because they don't realize you know the
quality of images
and how that works on websites then
there's some protection that that won't
make the site look bad
okay so some of the fields don't allow
HTML strips it out so there's some
protections in there like that so
setting it up like this definitely makes
it easier for people to enter content
and then it also gives me a lot of
control over how that contents displayed
and it takes that control away from the
WordPress editor which in this case we
want because it would be very easy for
someone who didn't didn't really know
anything about websites to kind of make
it look make it look bad I mean not that
they would mean to but it would be easy
you know if they could just go in and
put a bunch HTML and change the theme
and everything like you normally could
do on a wordpress site that wouldn't be
great so
let's see there's some questions I'm
going to come back to the questions in
the live chat so I see there's some
discussion going on there but I want to
get to this I'll come back at the end
and kind of join in the discussion a bit
let me show you now now that we've seen
the custom photo types what it's going
to look like I'm going to show you how
we make them I know I've briefly went
through this maybe last week at some
point I just kind of showed it now we're
actually going to make some things with
this and then we're going to add the
fields to it and then we're going to see
what it looks like when it comes in the
API so right here I've just been making
a list I've been going through the site
and making a list of all the sections
that right now you can't edit through
WordPress that need to be added I have
two ideas for how to do this some of the
sections would probably work well if I
just make them a page because if it's a
section that won't be repeated so for
instance like this section here is going
to be an intro section I always want
this section to just be about a
paragraph okay so I can make this
section just be a page and not even
necessarily a custom post type it would
just be a page with the name resources
intro okay we could give it that name
and then I could pull that page based on
the the slug which is and I kind of like
a string version of an ID WordPress
gives every page and post an ID that's a
number but then they also give it a slug
which is always a string that is a
unique identifier so in this case I
would search for this name of this page
okay so I'm going to do that I'm not
going to do the pages that right now
because I don't have to custom code
those so that's not as nice a thing to
do on on the video but for sections
they're going to repeat so like
in is it events now sorry courses
okay so courses some of these sections
will be static pretty much and so we
could just make them a page but some of
them like these are basically the same
thing repeated over and over again right
so it's just just text I did have a
request to add some images in here but
I'm not 100% sure how I'm going to
change how this looks to fit with that
so so that's that's coming but for now
at least these are all just going to be
repetitive sections so that's perfect
candidate for a custom post site so that
we can set okay I you know use we just
need a title and then we need text just
very simple now some of these like have
a little bit of more custom formatting
like this has you know this quote here
so there are going to be some that if
somebody knows what they're doing they
could throw some HTML in here and it
could work I'll have to make sure that I
have the style set properly on on this
end for it to work but you know that's
so I want to leave this whatever we make
as the input for this we want to make it
so that hTML is able to be put in so
we'll make that like a WYSIWYG editor so
I think this is a good candidate to do
first so let's do that and I've already
had it to the list I think I'm just
going to call it ministry tracks so I
see I know there's some stuff going on
in the live chat so I will get to it
I just want to kind of push ahead with
us now so that I can try to keep to keep
this to about an hour
total for the live stream so what I'm
going to do basically this makes a new
custom post type this this portion here
is basically thing that you need to
change there's one portion at the bottom
which basically initializes everything
okay so this you only need to add one
time this section down here
I'm just going to move down so we're
very clear that this is a new section
and these are custom taxonomies I'm not
going to do custom taxonomies today I
don't think I need these for anything on
the site at this point so as long as you
add this one time at the bottom here to
admit everything you can just put you
know all of your post types in one big
one big object I guess that's what I'm
not sure what this isn't PHP is okay so
one big function so this is greater
create new type function so yeah all
right so it all has to go in that
function sorry I'm just like trying to
make sure that I know what's going on in
the PHP and can explain it as best I can
I am NOT a PHP developer so if you know
more about PHP than I do which is likely
just bear with me here I know enough PHP
to make things change in WordPress and
upload files on a small website that's
about it so I'm going to take this I
just copied this and I'm going to paste
it below and I'm going to do some
kind of best editing here so you see
basically in this point I'll go through
them all oops I don't wanna so some of
these are going to be singular in some
plural so what I found is it's easiest
to just select the singular and then the
S on the end will come in so if you
shoot I don't have this in a repo maybe
I'll make like a gist or something and
make this available in case you want to
add this to WordPress and make your own
post type so I'll make a note of that
right now and make that available if you
want because I imagine you'd be super
hard to try to like look at this on the
video and type it all out as I'm moving
it around okay I may already have this
somewhere and get up and just to
forgotten about it but in case I don't
know add it and then I'll add a link in
this video so basically at this point
I'm just going to type in the name that
I want for this ministry tracks whoops
okay so now I'll go through this so
we're giving it the official name right
ministry tracks these names up here
these are going to be the ones that what
you usually see displayed in the admin
panel that's why I like you know this
this looks like normal text okay it's
not you know we're not doing like camel
casing or anything like that because we
want this to display you know in a
manner that's intelligible to people who
don't know anything about code in the
admin side so this is the singular name
and this is let me bring this over here
so I can it also be easier if I give you
like a side by side to show you what
these mean okay so the name - I need to
get this big enough
there we go all right so your name is
going to display here right your ad new
all right it's gonna see like ad new
whatever you want to say here so you
could change this if you wanted you
don't have to keep the defaults all
right when you go to you know edit the
item do this see you get the idea of all
these are going to show up somewhere in
the admin panel now down here these are
going to be the names that like you'll
use when you make a request to the API
or if you are going to do other things
like make another PHP plug-in to do
something else or even if you're making
a traditional WordPress site and you're
going to render these in PHP templates
and things these are what you'll use to
reference that so we just need to change
ministry and do I do I don't remember if
I usually do
hyphens or underscores or camelcase
let's see what I did here okay I did a -
great I'm not sure what's the convention
in PHP is it usually underscores or said
hyphens I see some underscores here at
this point it's I've already done it
differently so I don't really want to
change it because then I'll have to
change code in other places but just
though this may not be the conventional
way to do it in PHP just in terms of
style so this is actually you know this
is registering the post type we were
giving it the options here okay so these
options some of these it just depends on
what you want to do so you might not
need all of these but they're pretty
some of them are pretty like self
explanatory other ones so you might want
to check out
the documentation there's so much
documentation for WordPress stuff so
you'll be able to find exactly how to do
this you know has archived true right
this this means is this post type going
to have that archive function if you see
like on a lot of blogs you can go back
the archive to like you know go back to
the post from October 2016 right so do
we want it to do that yes we want to do
that I don't really know if I'll use
that function but in case I do I'm just
adding that is this public okay so you
can have post types that aren't meant to
be public they just you know you're
tracking data in the admin panel you
don't want people to see it you got to
be logged in and stuff so we want this
to be public and then we say supports
and these are going to be the fields in
here so I have actually taken these out
for this post type but normally let me
show you a post so by default this is
kind of the fields that you have I
actually added some up here but by
default you'd have write your title so
that's what this is talking about you
have your editor here you have and
decide I may have disabled excerpt so
excerpt is just a smaller text input
area where you could put in a custom
excerpt for your post otherwise I think
usually it's set to just take like the
first so many characters and use that if
you don't set it and then the the
thumbnail so you can set you can add or
take away these you know whatever you
want it to have I think some of these
have are probably like mandatory like I
think every post has to have a title so
you may not be able to take all of this
out but you can certainly you know add
things and but I have a kind of an
easier way to add and take away things
so I usually don't mess with this part
in the PHP exclude from search false
capability type so this is the type of
supposed so we're going to rewrite the
slug right so to ministry tracks and
we're going to this is the important
thing for the rest api do we want this
to show up and be accessible from the
rest api yes and do we want this to show
in the menu yes I'm pretty sure that I
it's been a long time since I mess with
this to check it but I'm pretty sure
this is like show in the in the admin
menu so like here in the menu so yes we
obviously want it to be here so that's
that's it that's all it takes to do a
custom post type so I'm going to save
this unfortunately I am not able to get
into the server right now
so I was hoping that I could just kind
of edit this like not that this would be
a great idea but I was going to kind of
just cowboy code this and edit it live
since it's like it's really basic
there's very little chance of me
breaking anything since its it's just a
really repetitive task copy and paste so
normally you wouldn't want to edit
things live but in any case I'm actually
going to have to copy and paste this and
then add this in so if you've never
added a plug-in to WordPress kind of the
the weird way to do it is I actually go
into the plugins section and I find my
plug-in which is here and you can edit
it now I think you have to be an
administrator so not every user can do
this which is a good thing so all those
people who I talked about that are going
to be editing this then won't be able to
do this so if you're making WordPress
site for client definitely block stuff
like this out for them so they can't
come in and mess with these because they
can definitely break your site so I'm
just going to paste in everything that
we did which this like I can't stand
like having to copy and paste stuff when
I'm working on a thing but Moe whoa
we will check here and look now we have
ministry tracks so if we go here we can
add a ministry track right now I haven't
set any of the stuff that we need I may
not actually have to set anything custom
here because we if you see the site what
do we need here we need a title and we
just need content here that's all we
need for right now at some point later
on we might need to add an image
somewhere but by default this comes with
a featured image so we can just use that
but for right now I don't want there to
be an excerpt and I don't want some of
these other fields to show that that
don't really make any sense in a
headless CMS so there's going to be a
field like if I were to put something
here and save it there'd be a field to
preview and it would show like what the
URL is going to be I don't want that
because if you click it it's not going
to show this site it's going to show
what it would look like if we're
actually using a wordpress thing usually
I don't even have a theme I I just block
everything so if you try to go click
that it will show you a blank page
occasionally I have it redirect to the
Rick Astley video for fun but but not on
a important site not on client side so
all right before I show you how to add
custom fields and take them away I'm
just going to check the live chat
briefly just to make sure you that you
all are with me let me scroll a little
bit see what I've missed
a few questions only answer a couple of
them while I'm while I'm here there's
not a lot and Ray I'm not sure I'm
pronouncing that right it's a nd REI let
me know how to pronounce that and I will
make sure I pronounce it correctly it
says why why would someone pay a
developer to code on my website when he
can make his own with WordPress that's a
good point to be honest with you for
some people in businesses it does make
more sense for them to try to just do
some type of simple site with WordPress
or with you know there are there other
things like what is it Squarespace or
there are a lot of different services
where you can go and just kind of drag
and drop build a website honestly if
you're just going to do a personal blog
and you're not really making money off
it then no don't pay a developer and I
mean I'm I'm a developer so I mean I
want I want people to pay me to make
sites but realistically it doesn't make
sense if you're very like a small
business and you need something very
simple let's say you're you're from an
area where like for instance the area
where I live is predominantly elderly so
the population demographics here just
like really really skewed in favor of
people over 60 it's just the economy is
really bad where I live so most of the
people when they graduate from high
school they leave because they can't
find a job here so that's how it is so
when I talk to people like a small local
business and they want to know about a
website
my advice is sometimes you know you
don't want me to do a website for you
because you're not really going to make
that money back that much you know your
clients aren't your clients aren't going
to be using your website that much if
you have a presence on you know Google
Maps that's what you need so I'm not Lee
talking about really small clients they
don't have a lot of money so I mean
obviously bigger companies should have a
website it should be a good website it
should not just be you know regular
defaults
they should have somebody it's a
professional working on it so that said
for this site in particular it needed to
be better I think I mentioned it earlier
so this site needed to be more than just
a normal WordPress site so that's why I
did it like this
and there's some other you know good
answers as well that other people added
to that uniqueness is one I mean yeah
the if you have a unique site that's
well done it definitely just adds at
least in my mind if I go to somebody's
site a company site if it's just basic
WordPress site I don't think badly of
them but if I go somewhere and they have
a site that's like wow how did they do
this site you know and I want to inspect
the code and see this is really cool for
me like it's just impressive I'm
impressed with a company that takes the
puts the thought into a site and has put
the resources into doing something like
that so not everybody's probably like
that but it makes a big impact on me you
know your site I mean consider your
website like the online home of your
business the online location so for some
companies they could do with just a
generic looking you know building to do
their business in right but for some
businesses they want to stand out they
want to have nice architecture nice
decorations right that that's kind of
the difference is between you know I
just have a little shop that looks like
all the other little shops on the street
or I have a place that people look at
under like wow you know they walk in and
it just attracts people because of how
nice it is that's kind of the difference
and if you want that you need to hire an
architect that's you know that knows
what they're doing and as you know some
creative ability and an interior
designer you know a decorator so
hopefully that answered your question I
probably spent too much time on that so
sorry if I
kind of over answered that let's see
so I'm just I'm just getting through I'm
almost to the end here of what's on the
live chat all right so here's requested
aft derp says is it better to have a
main parent component and render that to
the Dom or is it just the same to have
many parents all separately rendered to
the Dom competitor that's a no-no 70
suppose I'm not like a hundred percent
sure how to answer the question um let
me just show you I haven't showed you
any of the react stuff yet so let me
just briefly kind of show you how a page
works and it doesn't have to work like
this
this is kind of how things work in next
when you're using next to build react
stuff like this is my index so within
this index file and I like that maybe
I'm not really answering your question
here but I'll give it a shot you know
within my index this is actually it's
not a good example because I'm not
pulling in anything any other components
really let's go to resources that's a
better example
so I'm importing all these other
components these child components and
I'm pulling them in so you know the
sticky nav components here the title
components here all these all the cards
that I have on the page were just
iterating over this data and then adding
these cards to the page and that's a
separate component so that's that's how
I've been doing things I'm sure there
are other ways to do things hopefully
that clarified a little bit let me know
if it didn't and I'll try later on maybe
to give you a better explanation
I had asked a few minutes ago about the
different like using the - or the
underscore for PHP and it seems like the
underscore was kind of the way I should
have gone and Jake says the underscore
is the way to go but then you have an
underscore in the URL and you don't want
that so actually now that you
that I remember that is the reason that
is the reason why I did it like this and
not on this site but on like months ago
when I first started working with this I
had used underscore and then it I didn't
like then I ended up having to use
underscores later on in other places and
I didn't want to use underscores
everywhere so that's why I did go with
the - so thank you Thank You Jay
reminded me of that and the Patrick says
rickrolling clients priceless
yeah it is pretty funny I actually got
my I think I got my boss with that
before um yeah it's funny but yeah I
normally I don't do that for client
sites but I think I may still have some
WordPress installs where if you try to
go to like the admin page you get
rickrolled because I've changed the I
change the URL for the login for the
admin just to mess with somebody who
might be trying to like get into my site
and they're not supposed to be in there
alright so let's get to I don't want to
get completely off track here
where we're going here we go let me show
you how we're going to customize this
for editing so I have a plug-in called
advanced custom fields and it gives me
this extra menu item there's a pro
version of advanced custom fields but
there's a free version in this case the
free version does everything that I
needed to do so it's fine I have used
the pro version in other sites and it
has some functionality that if you need
it it definitely saves you time it's
worth the money I think it was like 25
dollars per site where you could pay
$100 and use it on as many sites as you
wanted I think it was in Australian
dollars too so I'm not sure what that
what that came out to and US dollars I
think it ended up being cheaper in US
dollars but at least at the time
so let's go into we're going to add new
and you get title let's go to ministry
tracks info um I will say this you
everything I'm about to do with this
plugin you can do in PHP and just code
it yourself I found that that was kind
of would take too much time for me just
because of my lack of experience with
PHP if you're good with PHP give it a
shot and that's one less plug-in you
have to worry about but I kind of this
is nice this this works it's free it's
well maintained plug-in it consistently
updated so I definitely recommend it and
I get no I'm not sponsored by this
plug-in so this is an honest
recommendation I get nothing for that so
what we're going to do here is want to
say when the post type equals alright so
when it equals ministry track okay then
all this stuff that we're about to do
will apply okay so we're going to apply
it to just that one and we have some
options as to where this is going to
display it's not really a big deal it's
your preference usually if the field is
like really important I don't want
people to miss it I put it high right
after the title but you can put anywhere
you want this like display style is um
totally up to you in terms of your
preferences I found that this the
seamless kind of looks cooler but the
standard fits in better with WordPress
so it's like it looks more like it's
supposed to be there and then here's a
place the place where we can actually
hide a lot of stuff that we don't need
so I'm just going to hide everything for
now because we're only going to show a
few things so we don't want the
permalink as I said because that'll take
you it'll take them to the wrong place
it'll be misleading we do want the
content editor
this post I don't always add this and
what we want that we don't want the
excerpt we don't want any of the normal
custom fields because we're going to add
our own custom fields here
we don't want discussion comments
because we're not going to have people
be commenting on this custom post type
we do want revisions so that they could
go back and see what's been changed we
do want the slug in case I need to
double check what the slug is you know
if I'm trying to troubleshoot something
we're going to keep the author and that
way people can see who's worked on that
post before we don't need format because
that has to do with the layout of a
WordPress theme and we're not using the
WordPress theme we're going to keep
featured image because at some point I
think we're going to add images to that
section so I'm just going to leave it in
there for now even though right now if
you put an image in there it wouldn't
display at all on our site in fact we
haven't linked this up to our site at
all so it has it is actually not going
to display depending on we're not going
to have time in this stream but maybe in
a future stream we can link this up I
know I've already showed how to do that
in a previous stream but maybe it would
be cool to do have like the whole thing
in order now we'll see let me know if
you're interested in that we are not
going to add any categories or tags at
this point we could always add it in
later but I don't really see any need
for this because of what we're going to
be using this for we don't need that if
this were more like a blog style thing
we would leave these and we don't need
the Trackbacks so we've got rid of a lot
of the stuff on the page if I wanted to
do a custom field which I don't need for
this one but let's just say I go here to
add a field I can add a label so I'm
just going to do some nonsense here it
gives it this field name this is the
name of the field that will show up in
the in the JSON so let me show you a guy
here so like anything that you put here
will show up under this
çf section in your JSON and this is the
name so you'll need to use this name in
your API call and then no not in the API
code you'll need to use this name when
you're rendering out the contents of
this so you can choose a field type to a
lot of different things you can choose
from and then if you get the pro version
there's even more you can have some
instructions so this is really important
if you're making it for clients you know
really spell out exactly what you want
in that field and how it how you want it
to be formatted you can make it required
or not you can give it a default value
placeholder text right so you can even
said okay where do I want this this text
to go so it really kind of nitpicky
things as to how you want to align this
but you know might be important this I
almost always choose no formatting
unless there's some really good reason
why I want people to be able to use HTML
in in whatever text area that is okay so
normally not I don't use that and
occasionally you don't want to character
limit so for these I don't need a
character limit because if you remember
on the page we're just showing and
hiding them so it's really not going to
be a big deal to have them be super long
because they won't be immediately
displayed to the user won't make the
page really long so we're not going to
have a character limit there but I would
recommend this for for things that you
don't want to make super long because it
would look bad put the character limit
in there and then usually people who
don't know about websites have a
tendency to write way too much text and
in general on a website you want less
text you know unless you're writing a
blog post or something then that's
understandable but you know if it's on
like your home page you to you know just
skip out people never read all the text
in any way so try to keep it short and
to the point so that's basically it I
would add this field and I don't really
want to keep it but I'll just add it
just for demonstration
purposes and I'm going to publish this
now when I go back up here to ministry
tracks and I go to add new we can see it
looks a bit different we don't have the
excerpt anymore actually there's no
option to get rid of these sharing
buttons I am this is not going to hurt
anything but actually if I can figure
out how to get rid of this I may as well
because it's kind of pointless in them I
just be distracting so basically we have
our all we have is just what we wanted
to include our title our content our
main content editor and then here's our
field so we added one field here and
then we just added another one in dis
left at blank but that's where they
would go like if we wanted to we could
have this display up here but that's it
you can see it just it looks like it's
meant to be there if blends in really
well with everything and that's where it
added so at this point what I would do
to kind of complete this process for
this post type is I would go in here and
basically at this point I would probably
copy and paste or I would probably have
somebody else do it because that's a
little bit of kind of a waste of my time
to just copy and paste so if I had maybe
like a student worker who needed to get
some hours in and maybe I would have
them copy and paste this into here fill
out all the tracks once I have the data
in there then I would go in and pull
this in so just like I'm doing here with
these resources where I get I can make a
call to the API here with fetch and then
I get that data back I showed you what
the JSON looks like and then I use that
data down here to populate the page so
that's what I would do for the the page
the courses page with the ministry
checks exactly like that so you can go
and get up right now and check out this
code and just kind of see what the next
step would be just by checking out one
of the pages where I'm actually
importing data where you see this get
initial props at the top of the
component so that's it so I've come in
it just slightly over an hours so we
kind of hit our goal today of being
about an hour I am going to keep going
for a couple more minutes just to answer
your questions so if you were only here
for the code you can stop watching now
and thanks for watching but if you do
have a few more minutes to stick around
for some questions go ahead and put your
questions in the live chat and I will
try to answer as many as I can as best I
can
and if your if you don't want to put
your question in the live chat if you're
a little nervous about that you can put
it in a direct message to me on Twitter
my Twitter a link to my Twitter account
is in the description for this video or
if you can't stick around for the answer
you can put the question in the comments
to this video and I will get to it I do
read all your comments and everything
that everyone sends me I read it all
sometimes it takes me a few days to get
to it but I do read it all and I will
respond alright so let me get to to some
of this live chat let's see there's not
a whole lot here so the question answer
session might be pretty short today
which that's fine because I so some of
you evidently are like staying up really
late to watch this because your time
zones are a lot different than my time
zone so I appreciate that that you know
you you like the screen enough to to
stay up like that but I don't want to
keep you up too late every night so I'll
try to be shorter than normal
let's see I'm going through I'm trying
to find a question here that I haven't
already addressed so haven't found very
much yet okay Sebastian asked can't you
redirect WP cat attack etics com2 the
real site yeah so I thought of that
before so just for some context here I
had said before that on the WordPress
select
normally when you do something in
WordPress and you save a post there'll
be a link here where you
check out your post or preview so
there's a preview button you preview it
with the way I've set it up here if you
click this preview it's going to take
you not to the site that you should go
to not to catechetical comm but it's
going to try to take you to the site
that would be there if we were using the
wordpress template and I usually just
completely disable the template so it'll
basically take you to a blank page but
you know at best it's just you know it's
misleading for people try to click that
and they think oh wow this isn't what
it's supposed to look like or they think
hey this site is broken what happened so
I just take that out I mean I I can take
out the preview button if I really
wanted to get into it into editing but
I'm not super worried about that right
now
Sebastian is saying couldn't you just
make all that redirect to the right
place on the on the actual catechetical
home site and I think that's probably
possible and I'd like to do that there's
actually another site that I did I can't
show you it's a it's like an internal
web site and my my bosses want it to be
they want it to stay private it's
basically just an internal bulletin
realistically like 90% or more of the
content there's no reason why I couldn't
be public and it probably is public
elsewhere but I'm not allowed to show it
but I will say that the person in my
department who has two input content for
that has requested before that that
exact feature of either that she can
preview what it's going to look like so
I'm working on a way to do that I would
like it to be able to for there to be a
feature where she can upload things and
be able to preview it and see it on a
page on the site I didn't actually build
it with react I made like a single page
app but I did it in like jQuery which
that's that site was kind of small
enough that it wasn't too much of a mess
but I wouldn't want to do that again
that was before I was confident enough
with react to build it so I'd like to
make a set page the
only she would be able to see that she
would be able to preview because right
now if she puts something in it you know
it's live so like it may only be live
for a second but she has to make it live
to see what it's really going to look
like which I mean that's not really a
good option so I mean I I definitely
should have in hindsight I should have
made that so that you there was some
type of preview feature built in but it
generally works there's not really a lot
of leeway with how you can enter the
content for that site but I'm definitely
working on that and if I get a solution
to it maybe I'll show you like on a demo
site since I can't show you the actual
site because that seems like it would be
valuable if you're trying to have a
similar set up to this all right
okay so daftar have said that data
answers question see that that question
was about I almost called you a he I'm
not sure if you he or she is sorry about
that
so dafter asked a question about how you
set up how you render the components and
things and react so I'm glad that that
they'd answer your question authority
Thor is here is that he nearly missed it
again
sorry you're missing it is it I don't I
don't know why you're missing it is it a
weird like it's it's usually a 2 p.m.
Eastern Time so for some reason it seems
like you're coming in an hour late is
that like you just can't make it earlier
or what how to make one too many
relationship between custom posts so
Andrew asks how to make one of many
relationship between custom posts Andrew
I'm not exactly sure what you're asking
if you're still watching could you
explain a little bit more because I'd
like to answer your question but I don't
I don't think I understand it well
enough right now to give you a good
answer Thor says it's 9:00 p.m. here
should not really a problem alright so
this is 9 p.m. there
tomorrow watch it start watching at 8
p.m. there and then you will be here on
time if you can also for those of you
who are watching really late all the
time
there may be some times where I have to
do an earlier stream so that might be
more convenient for you I'm thinking
like they're definitely going to be some
Monday's where I'll have meetings at 1
that will probably go really long so
I'll probably have to switch it up so
far I've been able to skip some of those
meetings because it wasn't really
relevant for me but I think I'm going to
have to start going to a few of them so
just heads up on that so there will be a
little change in time but that might be
good for some people maybe some some
people that can't you only watch live
may be able to Jake says nice job Jesse
I think you cleared some concepts that
took me quite some time to figure out on
my own
awesome I'm glad I could be of some
assistance to you Jake Roland says today
is stark contrast to yesterday's it's
just 12:35 a.m. we went to 2:10 a.m.
yesterday yeah yesterday was super long
I was I was actually super exhausted I
remember yesterday I said I had to go to
the store and pick up some stuff I was
so exhausted after the livestream
yesterday that I didn't I went home and
just relaxed because I couldn't I
couldn't even make it I was super hungry
and tired and I thought I'm not going to
try to go to the store now I'll probably
buy everything and because I'm so hungry
and tired
let's see Thor asks why are you using
WordPress oh ok sorry there's one before
that so smilers asked what application
is it I'm not sure what you're referring
to I think I'm missing something so
smile is a type of redactors you okay
what type / - is using for code you mean
that code editor uh it's if you mean my
code editor I'm using Adam if you mean
like the framework I'm using react on
the on the front-end side of things to
render everything and then I'm using
WordPress
to manage the content but I'm not using
the template system that WordPress has
so hopefully that answers your question
let me know if it didn't so Thor says
why are you using WordPress for this
purpose is there nothing better for this
for example a simple Django application
or something like this the two main
reasons why I'm using WordPress for this
is number one because a lot of people
who have no experience at all with code
are going to be editing this and there's
going to be a high turnover rate for
people who are editing this so they need
to be able to be trained very quickly
and use this so WordPress is very user
friendly in that way the second reason
is because this site was a really tough
schedule I didn't really have time to
learn anything and I don't know
something like Django
I do I have done this exact thing with
WordPress in the past so I knew that I
could get it done on time if I did it
this way so that's generally not a great
idea to use something just because hey I
know how to do it I'm just going to keep
doing it this way but in this case it
actually did work out well for the
project so if on future projects if I
have more time and it would work out
better I'm definitely open to using
something other than WordPress for
content management actually let me know
in the live chat or in the comments what
you would recommend using if I if we
weren't using WordPress what should have
been used what do you think and maybe if
I get some time I'll check out your
suggestions and see because I'm I'm
certainly open WordPress is a little bit
of a resource hog it can be on the
server so something more lightweight as
long as it's still user friendly for for
people who don't know about code I would
definitely be open to using the other
thing is WordPress has a huge user base
and there's a lot of great documentation
on it so that's really helpful for me at
times when I need to do some custom
things with it
hooligan soft says hey hey what's up
thanks for watching
door says testing and production is
great yeah I don't have a copy of the
WordPress install either locally or on
another server I'm thinking about
getting one it's probably a good idea to
get one I probably should do it but I
just don't have a setup right now to be
honest with you I'm a little bit
intimidating with the idea of like how
do I sync up the database do I have two
separate databases and try to keep them
in sync do I pull from the same database
but if I do that is that really like a
decent development environment you know
because so whatever I don't know how to
do that there is somebody else Brian
works with me here and he has worked
more with stuff like this and using
WordPress and databases so I'm gonna
maybe talk to him a little bit about
that and see what he recommends in terms
of having a like a testing environment
or test you know a testing development
server and if you all have any input on
that I would appreciate it as well
because I probably should have it you
know in general you should never be
editing a site live if if you don't have
to if it's not an emergency hooligan
soft says can you make tutorials from
making WordPress theme from scratch um
that would be really cool unfortunately
I don't think I could make a good
tutorial on making a wordpress theme
from scratch because to do a theme from
scratch you have to have some knowledge
of PHP at least enough to do the
WordPress PHP thing and I'm not
confident in my skills to do that so I
do know how to do a lot of customization
from scratch I have I have honestly I
have built a really basic theme from
scratch before but that was a long time
ago so I don't think I could do it
justice I wouldn't feel comfortable
putting out a tutorial like that I mean
you all know I mean I attempt a lot of
things that where I don't really know
what I'm doing so I'm not opposed to
doing that but to actually do like a
from beginning to end tutorial on
something I would want to be more
knowledge of
also but if anyone else knows of a good
tutorial to make a theme from scratch
please you know let let us know in the
live chat or in the comments so that it
can be a nice resource for whoever needs
to do that rohan says i don't know how
WP handles content but you can have an
internal temp entry and use preview to
generate page from that ok that's
interesting I will have to keep that in
mind and maybe look look up some more on
that I'm just thinking about that for a
second ok thank you for that suggestion
andrew says is front end served by
wordpress or some node app it's a node
it's a node app so Andrew I'm using on a
set to WordPress lives on one
digitalocean droplet and then on another
droplet we're really to other droplets I
have clones of a node app it's react
that actually renders all the data that
it's getting from WordPress through the
WordPress API and there's there's a load
balancer that your shifts traffic
between those two copies of the the node
app another thing that I didn't mention
when I was talking about WordPress that
I'll mention briefly I just remembered
the cool thing about using the WordPress
API for this is the same content that
you put into WordPress you can use for
your website
you could potentially add a theme on to
this and have a traditional WordPress
site if you wanted to there's nothing
stopping you from doing that as well you
can pull the data into anything that can
get anything that can use an API a REST
API and get in can process JSON data so
and any app probably some Internet of
Things stuff I've actually had an idea
to make an Alexa skill for the Amazon
echo that would pull data from the
WordPress API and like read you the blog
posts so I don't know if somebody's
already done that and you know about it
let me know and then maybe I won't do it
because it's been done already but if it
hasn't been done I'd like to do it and
or if you want to take my idea and do it
first just let me know because I think
be cool just to use I won't be mad if
you steal my idea but that's kind of
cool that you could use it in a lot of
different places so they'd all lives in
one place and it's all easily editable
and like imagine like if you wanted to
keep everything in your organization all
sync together in terms of the you know
let's say you have like a business and
you wanted like your times that you're
open or even like on let's say your
restaurant you change your menu
frequently well you change your menu
here in one place and it automatically
syncs to you know you're at let's say
you had an app I know this would be
weird for a restaurant to have an app to
and an Alexa skill and all this and now
all of a sudden all the data is updated
instantly everywhere there's some
definitely some value in that and can
save whoever's editing your content it
saves them a lot of time all right let
me continue on I'm nearly at the end
here the live chat so where the stream
is getting longer and in spite of my my
efforts to make it shorter today it
keeps going longer so sorry about that I
just you know I don't want to leave you
all hanging if you have questions so I
definitely let's say this I want to try
to cut it off at an hour and a half so
that'll be in ten minutes we'll cut it
off even if I haven't gotten through
everything and then maybe I'll just try
to answer your questions like maybe at
the beginning of the next stream like
tomorrow stream if I don't get to them
all let's see Thoris will try it's not a
time problem where something is just
probably remembering it she probably set
up reminder event or something okay all
right cool Thor that's the Souris
talking that's we were talking about
that the time that he was kind of late
getting in here to watch it so it's just
a remembering thing so cool if you um if
you're not already subscribed to the
free code can't channel I think though
if you have your notifications turned on
and you subscribe I think they will
alert you so you'll get like if you have
the YouTube app it will alert on your
phone you're going to notification
or it can do like desktop notifications
as well so that might be helpful to you
I also post on Twitter usually like
beforehand so that could be another
reminder Andrew says custom post author
custom post book add books to author
okay so Andrews clarified its earlier
question about how to make relationships
between custom posts so yeah this is
possible let me think for a second
because I'm I have worked with this sort
of thing before it's been a long time so
let me let me just think for a second to
make sure I I remember what's going on
okay so here's what you can do um I do I
believe in WordPress you can make so you
would have the two custom posts write
author and book that books to author how
did I do this before
you know what I think I didn't solve it
in the best way so I wanted to be able
to add books to author and Link it but I
think what I ended up doing instead was
did I make a taxonomy I may have made a
taxonomy or some so I don't think I
solved it correctly but I think it's
possible I just don't I don't know how I
can't remember exactly how I did a
similar thing so I don't want to give
you an answer so sorry I can't give you
a good answer on that but I can tell you
that I'm I'm almost positive that it's
possible because I did look into it
before I just
I either couldn't get it working or it
didn't seem like I needed it that much
that it was worth the time but I I mean
that's that's definitely something that
comes up so I'm sure the answers is out
there Jake says luca node who's pulling
data from workforce api ok awesome so
jake had already answered the question
so sorry I should have read ahead and
then I wouldn't have had to answer that
John says I'm late for any fix all right
sorry John you can watch the replay the
replay will be oh man so we had a couple
people who were late so the replay will
be available in like a minute after I
end this stream so I mean if you want to
participate in the questions and stuff
just add them in the comments below the
video
andrew says we're press gives you fast
bootstrapper back-end and already has
json api enabled with all endpoints yes
excellent that's that's a great point
yeah you you don't have to build any of
that it just it comes it's just there
and if you're using like managed hosting
or you know like like GoDaddy or
something like that they're like you
know regular shared hosting account
there's usually a one-click install for
WordPress and it takes five minutes so
in five minutes you have a REST API you
know that's that's really easy so I'm
sure they're probably better ways to
build an eight
but if you don't know how to do that I
don't have time to mess with that then I
mean you can't beat that that's that's
just simple really simple Thor says ok
thanks for answering never heard people
using WordPress for this purpose just
wondering yeah it's actually it's kind
of new or the WordPress API has been
around for a couple of years but it's
been in like beta stage for a while it's
only within the last year I think that
it's it's like officially part of
WordPress core used to be you had to get
a separate plug-in and enable it and
stuff so for a while there it was
recommended not to use it on production
sites I did still use it anyway because
in my experience like it worked there
were very few breaking changes that ever
occurred and if it did happen it was
well documented so I never had a problem
with it but it's it's only recently that
it's I think like at a stable enough
point that a lot of people are starting
to use it
Andrew says yes is a good practice to
keep staging in production even local in
sync
yeah that's the that's the goal that's
what I should have set up so I pretty
much have that for the node um a part of
this but just not for the WordPress part
Andrew says this is how WordPress that
WordPress takes templates in theme I'm
not sure what that was in response to
Andrew so I don't remember I mean what I
was talking about at that point so sorry
Jordan says what size drop list ease
actually so this is really cool um Oh
Roland says the stream keeps dropping I
haven't been watching the the stream
stats oh I didn't see sorry about that
actually when it goes that's weird okay
sorry it was dropping right now it seems
it's it's holding I'm like over 5,000
kilobits per second so it should be good
right now so sorry about the drop I mean
obviously I don't really have control
over that can
action but I usually have a really good
connection at work so Jordan the droplet
size I'm using five-dollar droplets for
everything so the to clone like no
droplets are both five-dollar droplets
and then WordPress's on a five dollar
droplet usually it's recommended not to
go with the $5 for WordPress but because
I'm using it in this way just the
headless part of WordPress and it's not
having to do any like rendering of
templates at all I've found that I can
get away with putting WordPress on a
five-dollar droplet and it's still
really fast and it holds up
I definitely be a point where if I get
too much traffic I would have to upgrade
it but that's actually been really nice
that I'm able to to run it on a
five-dollar droplet I'm also going to
take advantage of once once all the post
types and everything really get bailed
out I'm going to turn on caching for the
API and that's going to decrease the
load on WordPress even further and then
I do have caching set within node at the
server level and then there's also
caching going on on the client side with
the serviceworker so there are three
levels of caching if I have time I may
even route this through CloudFlare and
so there will essentially be four levels
of caching going on so once if a request
even got all the way back to WordPress
it would be somewhat rare so it'll allow
me it will allow me to run these on very
cheap droplets because I'm kind of
protecting them from the brunt of all
the traffic that you would normally have
on a wordpress site so so for right now
that works I think is pretty cool that I
can run it on lower droplets I mean not
that I need to I'm sure you know for
this project there was there was a
budget that was large enough that I
could have done a larger droplet but
there's really no reason to the site is
running very quickly and at least for me
from from my testing it's been running
very quick
and the API calls are coming back you
know very very fast you know within
milliseconds
let's see Jonathan says there's a PHP
myadmin on your host server where
WordPress is hosted this gives you full
capabilities to run sequel off the
database on the backend as well yeah
actually I don't have PHP myadmin
installed when I run WordPress on
digitalocean
so I'm not sure I actually had my
colleague Brian set up the WordPress
instance so he may have installed PHP
myadmin or something like that I'll have
to ask him about it but um when I've
done installs of WordPress on digital
ocean
I haven't installed anything and if I do
need to mess with sequel I've just done
it from the command line and that's
worked for me if you use a host like for
some sites I do have on GoDaddy and I
use SiteGround for some sites too
those usually come with like cPanel and
PHP myadmin so that makes it a lot
easier if you have access to PHP myadmin
and can use it use that it's way easier
than the command line for that normally
I do like the command line but for for
doing database stuff I don't like it as
much
all right last andrew says last question
for me do you sync your containers
databases when using load balancing
thanks so so no actually so the
containers so the node apps have no
databases and those two containers are
where the load gets balanced between the
API calls all go to just one instance of
WordPress so there doesn't need to be
any load balancing to there because you
know obviously there's just one and
that's where the database sits so so no
I don't have to deal with syncing that
to any of the you know for load
balancing purposes
okay someone asks and I can't pronounce
this because it's in Russian says who is
from Russia or who is speaking on
Russian let's study together so I don't
speak Russian if anybody else speaks
Russian then you know get together maybe
you guys can study together and you says
better use my sequel workbench app to
connect to database instead of PHP
myadmin which has load on your server
all right good to know I'll have to
check that up Andrew knows Russian
awesome okay and that's the end of the
live chat did I make it um two minutes
over what I wanted to be so almost made
it lost track of time there at the end
so still have but we have 32 viewers
still even after all that time so a
little bit lower than normal but it's
been a long stream okay somebody joining
us just now hey how's it going thanks
for watching
so I'll see tomorrow I should be I don't
think I have any meetings or anything so
it should be same time 2:00 p.m. Eastern
Time
thanks for watching I and feel free to
ask me any questions and I appreciate
all the the great interaction we've had
in the live chat today and anyway for
the for all the people that thumbs down
this I had one earlier please let me
know why you thumbs down it I won't be
upset with you I just want to make it
better so thanks for watching have a
great day and I will see you tomorrow